- We looked for houses.
I picked those one I like
and then yeah, he bought it.
♪ Ooh, that sugar sweet ♪
♪ You got what I need ♪
♪ Sippin' on the potion ♪
♪ All that good emotion ♪
- Okay, the first thing I'm looking for
is, like, plastic surgery.
(everyone laughs)
Like, you know, if he paid for your BBL.
- I have fake (beep).
- Oh, okay.
- I'm looking at lashes,
because lashes are very expensive.
(Allie chuckles)
So, I'm looking at your lashes.
(Allie and Alexis laugh)
- Mine are just, like, falsies.
- Are they?
Oh, yours are?
Oh my god, they look so good.
- Thank you.
- Yours could be extensions.
- Your hair is done very well,
and you have Asian-style hair,
which can be very expensive
to bleach and keep healthy.
So, I'm also looking at your hair.
- 'Cause, I was like,
maybe they're extensions
because they're really long.
I think you look very expensive right now.
- Extensions, yeah.
I was thinking she was the
most expensive as well.
- So, I feel like I'd put you first.
- I agree to also put her first.
(Allie chuckles)
(smooth music)
I'm aiming at putting her second.
- Yeah.
- Yes.
Your hair is literally dyed beautifully.
- Thank you.
- It's just perfectly styled.
- Like, no flyaways or nothing.
- And I feel like we're
more casual, so it's like-
- Yeah, it's a little difficult.
- It's kind of like, who knows?
- What kind of boots are those?
- These are definitely...
I honestly don't know.
I got them so long ago.
- Oh, shoot.
They do look expensive, though.
- [Allie] They do.
- Yeah, I think you would be next.
- 'Cause your outfit's really nice, yeah.
- I feel like if it was my order,
I'd pick her next, and then her next,
and then the last two the same.
- You think?
- Oh, okay.
- I was literally thinking the same thing.
- Okay.
(smooth music)
- I am luckily able to google
him, so I can say that.
- Ooh.
- Same.
(Candice laughs)
- Oh, okay.
- This is the one I met in person.
- He looks 21.
- Andrew Tate vibes.
(everyone laughs)
- He definitely looks smart,
like he's talking about Crypto.
(Alexis laughs)
- So, here's mine.
- Ooh! Oh my goodness.
- He looks so young!
- He looks put-together!
- He's only 34, so-
- He looks rich.
- [Candice] He looks younger than that.
- He looks so put-together
and like, clean.
- Yes.
- He looks like he's swimming in money.
(everyone laughs)
- He doesn't like pictures of himself,
so I got a video of him last week, but...
(Allie chuckles)
- Videos work.
- It doesn't say much.
(Allie laughs)
- Wow!
- It says a lot.
- It says a lot!
- Yeah, he's a baller.
- I met a Sugar Daddy on a yacht.
He just wants hot girls on the boat,
so he'll just say, "Invite
all your girlfriends,
and let's have a boat day."
- Okay, here's mine.
- He looks so sweet.
- Oh, yeah.
- [Stormi] No, he does look sweet,
but he definitely looks
like he's giving Jeff Bezos.
(everyone laughs)
- Yeah, he looks super rich.
This is my Sugar Mama.
This is her profile.
- Very pretty!
- So cute.
- You're actually the
first person I've met
that has a Sugar Mama.
- Really? Wow, okay.
I get that a lot, actually.
(everyone laughs)
People are always, like, shocked about it.
- [Producer] All right, so she's here?
- Yes, she's here. Yeah.
(exciting music)
- Oh, that's sweet!
- That's so sweet!
- He looks like an angel.
(April laughs)
- He's taking care of flowers.
- [April] Yeah.
(everyone laughs)
- I would have to say that
she's number one, just because-
- I'm gonna...
I would put you at-
- Me?
- Well, also her too,
but I think she's number one
'cause she's the one that like-
- He looks like Jeff Bezos.
- Okay.
- That suit and everything.
That's not the suit.
- And then I would say you number two.
- He was, like, very clean looking.
- [Daniel] Yeah.
(Alexis chuckles)
- Wait, yours too.
'Cause you know, he
doesn't have to dress up
to go to work.
- True.
- That is true.
- Like, I think you should remain up here,
but I don't know if you should switch.
- I think it's fine just
the way it is right now.
What do you guys think?
- You think so?
- Okay.
- I don't really know.
- I feel like maybe you two should switch.
- I kind of agree with that as well.
- With them switching?
- Switching, possibly, yeah.
- Okay.
Yes! I'm just kidding.
(everyone laughs)
(Daniel chuckles)
It's not a competition.
- My Sugar Daddy is pretty
high up in a company.
It's just kind of nice to know
you'll have someone to rely on
if you need your bills paid.
(Allie laughs)
And he also likes to send gifts, as well.
- Mine, he is a doctor,
but he also is a high up at a
very prestigious university.
- Ooh.
- We take a lot of trips.
I'm on his AmEx Platinum card.
- Whoa!
- Okay!
That's intense.
- Wow.
- So, the one I showed you is a lawyer,
and he also does Crypto.
I don't know what that
means, but he does that.
- I was right.
- [Alexis] You were right.
- You were right, yeah.
- And then my other one,
he invests in real estate,
and then another one owns
a real estate brokerage.
(Daniel whistles)
- Wow.
(Alexis chuckles)
That's a lot.
- I know.
- Well, my Sugar Mama is
SugarMamaKara on TikTok.
She's famous.
- I was just gonna say, she
looks like she creates content.
- Yeah, she actually talks about
how to be either a
Sugar Mama to the woman,
or how to get a Sugar
Mama to the young guys.
So, she's kind of like educating people
on the Sugar Mama world.
- That's cool.
- Yeah, and she makes a
lot of money on TikTok too.
(Daniel chuckles)
- I don't see any of them that often,
but one of them makes a lot of deals
for different governments.
And another one is a professional player,
having to do with gambling.
- Does he win a lot?
- Yeah.
(everyone laughs)
- So, mine are both entrepreneurs.
They own a few companies.
- [Allie] Nice.
- Like, one specifically
has a few laundromats,
and another one has a jewelry
store and a weed company.
- [Allie] Smoke weed every day.
- We underestimated her.
- And a bunch of weed former
that I don't quite know.
- I feel like she needs to come up some,
'cause weed company,
jewelry store, that's money,
I feel like.
- Like here?
- Yeah.
- This is so hard.
- I know.
- It is hard, yeah.
- Am I allowed to move myself down,
just by listening to everybody?
- You could, but I mean,
I wouldn't do that.
- I just want to raise her.
I kind of want to raise you.
- I feel like you should be-
- Yeah, that's what I'm saying,
'cause listening to the American Express,
the Platinum card, Miss Ma'am.
- How often do you guys
see your Sugar Parents?
- [Daniel] That's a good question.
- Once a month, sometimes more.
- Once a week. We go out to dinner.
We only meet in public, really.
If you're doing what you gotta do,
and you get a nice meal out of
it, that's all that matters.
(everyone laughs)
- [Daniel] There you go.
That's what life is all about.
(glasses clink)
- What about for you?
- I don't see mine in person anymore,
'cause I moved here from Jersey.
- [Allie] Oh, wow.
- Okay.
- So I see him like once a week,
but he still sends me
money whenever I want,
and, like, a set amount every week.
- Oh, okay.
- And all the others are
literally just online,
so I don't see them.
- Yeah.
For me, once week or once every two weeks,
depending on the week.
- I see mine every weekend,
usually Fridays to Sundays.
Like, Friday night,
Saturdays all day and night,
and then, like, Sunday a little bit.
- You said that she makes a
lot of money off of TikTok,
and I know that world and I understand,
so I kind of want to raise
him up a tad as well.
- Okay. I would like that, yeah.
(everyone laughs)
- I don't know where to move you up to,
so if y'all want to help.
- I think maybe like all the way...
(everyone laughs)
No, I'm just joking.
- I actually keep moving myself down,
but I think it would actually make sense
for you to be second, yes.
- I think in front of you.
- I'll take it.
- What does your guys' day
to day kind of look like?
- I have kids.
I'm a single mom.
They're six and seven, so
they don't know what I do.
I've been thinking, like,
what exactly I'm gonna say,
because they know I travel a lot,
and I'm always working,
but they haven't asked me.
So, I take them to school,
and then I pretty much just so home.
I schedule my days where
I have content days,
or, you know, normal mom things,
but honestly I don't have a set schedule.
I just make money,
do whatever I wanna do pretty much, yeah.
- I'm happy with her being there.
- Yeah.
For me, Monday through Thursday,
when I'm not with my Sugar Mama,
I basically just get to chill, hang out,
do whatever I want.
I'm actually living in a
mansion in LA right now.
My Sugar Mama is paying the rent for me.
- Nice.
- My lifestyle's pretty chill too.
I wake up, go to the gym.
- Might be a theme.
- Yeah.
- I thought maybe there'd
be one person that's like,
"Oh, I do a nine to five." I don't know.
(Allie and Alexis laughs)
- That's literally me.
- Okay!
- And that's why you're over there.
(everyone laughs)
- I'm not surprised.
- But yeah, I like to take
monthly content trips,
'cause if I'm gonna take spicy pics,
I'd rather do it in the
Bahamas instead of my house.
And, it's obviously paid for.
- Right.
Hearing that, I also...
I just keep moving myself.
- She's like, "Right."
(everyone laughs)
- But hearing monthly trips
that are paid for and stuff,
I think you deserve to be
a little higher as well.
- What's the most expensive
thing they've ever bought you?
- Ooh.
- I was literally gonna ask that.
- I was renting for a long time.
He pays my bills, you know, he was like...
He's big on investing,
and making sure he's getting
a return on investment.
So, he's like, "I'm tired of paying rent."
So, we looked for houses.
I picked which one I like
and yeah, he bought it.
- Wait, so is it, like, under your name?
- It's under both of our name.
- [Candice] Oh.
- Okay, homegirl's good
to be up in that front.
(everyone laughs)
- Yeah.
I think I'm gonna take a step over here.
(everyone laughs)
We've got a big gap.
Yeah, the most expensive thing
my Sugar Mama's bought me.
She paid off my BMW.
That was monthly, though.
It wasn't straight up.
She's bought me a ton of
designer, Dolce shirt for 400.
Cost of like, anything
I want, she gets me.
That's on top of my pay, too.
It's just, like, literally extra stuff.
Nothing like a house, but...
(everyone laughs)
What about you?
- My boobs.
(Alexis chuckles)
Anytime I wanna go anywhere, they're like,
"What do you need? Do you want the jet?
Do you want me to just pay for it?"
Get my plane ticket and
I'm like, "The jet."
Always take the jet.
But it's not mine, so
he didn't buy it for me,
but that's still a lot of money.
- Yeah.
- The jet.
- No, definitely a lot.
- And he's bought me, like, Chanel bags,
Prada bags, Louis Vuitton, as well.
- So, do we wanna move her second?
- Yeah. I was thinking that too, yeah.
We should move.
- Also, as you were talking, I was like,
"Wow, your teeth are white."
You definitely have gotten
some help and I love that.
I wish I could.
- Thank you.
- For me, I would say
security deposit, rent.
That's really the main
thing that I ask for
whenever I'm asking for help from him,
because that's probably
the most stressful thing
a person who's 21 has to deal with.
- For me, well, probably my Chanel bag,
and also, I do a lot of weekend getaways.
So, flights, I feel like, accumulated.
- I feel like I always ask them
to just CashApp me directly,
then I'll let them know
what I get with it.
- You use it. Okay.
- Smart.
- So, I own a house, so
I need to pay off stuff.
So, I'll just say, "Okay,
this went toward this."
- Wait, you own your own house, you said?
- Yeah, 'cause I'm trying
to get rich like them.
I think that's the main
reason why I started
trying to look for more Sugar Daddies.
Not for, like, a main thing of income,
but I wanted to learn how
to create wealth myself.
- [Producer] What's the nature
of your guys' relationship
with your Sugar Parents.
- Mine are all platonic.
That's why I have a nine to five.
- Honestly, me as well.
I mean, I'm looking for a job,
just because I love him as if I would say,
"I love this girl, too."
Like, I love my best friend.
Like, my mom even knows that
he's the sweetest person ever.
Even she's like, "How is he?"
- Yeah.
- But for the most part, yeah.
Not even for the most part.
Everything has been
platonic with everyone.
And if there's even been
a question about that,
I immediately shut it off,
'cause that's just not how I
want my relationships to be,
in terms of getting financial help.
- Exactly.
- Yeah, with the main one, it is romantic.
- Mine are just, like,
really good friends,
nothing romantic.
Like, we kind of know what it is.
- Mine's, like, interesting.
- Our relationship is very unique.
He's only with me and I'm only with him,
'cause I'm not gonna pay
him to be with other women.
That's just stupid,
and it would not make me feel good.
That's why I'm paying you so much.
- Mine doesn't care.
He is married, though,
so maybe that's why.
(everyone laughs)
- Does she know about you?
- Yeah, she knows about me.
- Oh, okay. That's good.
- Does she know the full
extent of what he does?
No.
- Oh!
(Allie laughs)
Well, she's gonna find out.
I'm kidding!
- I'm not gonna lie.
I'm kind of a, maybe a
diva, something like that.
I feel like that's my personality.
I'm a Leo.
- I'm really confident with this.
- Okay.
- Same.
- I feel like you need to move up.
- I kind of agree as well.
- Yeah, 'cause she goes
on trips with them.
- I agree.
I feel like we're kind of on
the same page a little bit.
- [Candice] Yeah.
- [Producer] You guys
feel good where you're at?
(chattering in agreement)
- I feel like our numbers
will be really close.
- I don't know. We'll see.
- Really?
(Candice and Allie laugh)
- [Producer] Sixth, we have Candice
at $1200 average monthly.
- That's me.
- Hey, you're still getting money, though.
(Allie chuckles)
- [Producer] In fifth, we have Allie.
$3000 average monthly.
- [Daniel] Whoa.
- Why do I feel like we're
actually kind of right?
- Yeah, I think so.
- [Producer] In fourth,
we have a tie actually
for $3000 average monthly.
- Oh my god!
- Yeah.
(Allie and April laugh)
- [Producer] And in third, Daniel.
- No way!
(everyone laughs)
- Whoa!
- Wait, how much?
- 35.
- Okay, nice.
- [Producer] In second, Lexi.
$10,000 average monthly.
(Allie gasps)
- [Allie] Oh, my god.
- That's a big gap right here.
- First, Asia.
$15,000 average monthly.
- We did such a good job!
(group chattering)
Spot on.
- Wow.
- That was awesome.
- I didn't expect it, honestly,
because I didn't think
$10,000 was, like, a lot.
(Alexis laughs)
I make more on my OnlyFans
than through sugaring,
so that's just a little extra.
- I feel like it's interesting
to see myself here,
because I feel like there's a stigma
that Sugar Babies are, like,
skinny, and like, blonde,
but I feel like that's what
brought me so much success.
There's somebody for everybody, you know?
- I really thought I was
gonna be, like, at the bottom.
Going into it, I assumed there
would be a lot of luxury bags
and all that.
- Me as well.
Well, that shows you, even
when they're a Sugar Baby,
you don't have to make,
like, hundreds of thousands
of dollars.
You can still have a very normal life
with just the support that you need.
I'm pretty satisfied with
just having my needs met.
So, even if I'm not getting
paid a great, great amount,
I'm still getting paid with fun.
I just kind of like being
able to say I've done stuff
that maybe not everyone has
a chance to say they do.
- Yeah, I feel like as a Sugar Baby,
half the world judges me for it.
- Mm-hmm.
- Because, like, we're looked down upon,
because, "You use people for money."
But, we're not using them for money.
We're giving them what they want.
It's a transaction.
You go to the store,
you wanna buy something,
you have to give them what they want.
They want money. You swipe your card.
"Okay, here's my money. Let
me get that, like, peas."
- My earring just came out.
- How much is that earring?
(everyone laughs)
- The main thing I want people
to take from this video,
and I wanted the intentions to be for,
is to don't judge people on
how they make their money,
because it's their life
and they're allowed to
do whatever they want.
And, if they're happy and they're safe,
and it's consensual,
that's all that matters.